okay well thank you for having come back
i'm going to talk now about population
genetics more specifically and
developments in population genetics but
just to remind you that i made this
distinction between Darwinism and
neo-darwinism neo-darwinism included
Mendelian inheritance and neo-darwinism
became the established view of evolution
and to a large extent still is and
population genetics was an important
part of that particularly the
theoretical developments by Fisher and
right and holding but population
genetics the contribution to the
population genetics to neo-darwinism was
to establish the plausibility of the
mechanism that is natural selection
acting on Mendelian variants could
account for evolution and it was very
much of a theoretical argument a
plausibility argument there was a great
deal that was not known about population
genetics in the first part of the 20th
century so in much of the development
was theoretical with a simple reason
that there was almost no data to analyze
so there was this general agreement that
Mendel ISM and evolution Darwin's theory
of evolution were compatible that there
was no specific knowledge about exactly
how Mendel ISM contributed to variation
exactly the details that you would like
to know there were no specifics of
population genetics and so the 20th
century is largely from our point of
view is largely a story of the how
population genetics went from this
abstract and general subject to a very
specific subject of concerned with
details that we now have great access to
so just to emphasize
okay just to emphasize what was not
known despite the contribution of
population genetics is very simple
things how many genes were in the genome
not really a population genetic question
but obviously related to it what
fraction of the genes are polymorphic
that is what fraction carried two or
more Mendelian alleles and what fraction
were fixed for only one allele how many
alleles / polymorphic gene if there were
there two or were there 25 people didn't
know what were typical differences
between in genotype between members of
the same species no we'd look we could
look at any species just the way Darwin
did and see that there was abundant
variation at the phenotypic level at the
level you could see what was the genetic
basis for those differences was that a
few men Delian jeans wear a lot of
Mendelian jeans how did those genes
affect variation whoops what are we
doing here
baby
the same question you can ask what
fraction of genes are flying over well
tell you later what are the differences
in genotype between members of this of
different species so we can see just as
we can look at differences within a
species you can look at differences say
between humans and chimpanzees or
between one species have planted another
how many genes account for those
differences we have no idea people had
no idea that at the time they knew there
was Mendelian inheritance they believed
in the multifactorial theory and they
believed that mentally mentally and
jeans were the basis for inheritance
they believed that natural selection
acting on Mendelian genes could change
allele frequencies and that was
consistent with the pattern of evolution
but that was it and furthermore even if
we with the pattern there's the pattern
of variation people also did not know
what maintained variation thanks to
right and Fisher and others we knew that
genetic drift would cause Emile's to be
lost and thanks to halt dein and Fisher
in particular we knew the natural
selection could act to either maintain
genetic variation through what's called
balancing selection that is somehow for
some reason heterozygotes are better
than homozygotes but we did so we had
mechanisms population genetic mechanisms
could eliminate variation population
genetic mechanisms could maintain
variation but what was actually
maintaining variation we didn't know we
knew mutation had to ultimately be the
source of all new variants but is the
availability of mutation limiting in
evolution you can imagine a thought
experiment where you would turn off
mutation that suddenly no more new
mutations would appear would evolution
immediately grind to a halt or
devolution proceed for a very long time
acting on existing genetic variation
already present in the species we can't
do that experiment but we could ask that
question and imagine what the answers
would look like
people had no idea and what forces
maintain phenotypic variation and too
does genetic variation do differences
between species are they the result of
natural selection or they result of some
other forces including genetic drift or
forces that we don't yet know about so
there was a lot not known despite the
agreement about the importance of
population genetics now in the first
part of the first half of the 20th
century there were several ways to study
genetic variation I mean people didn't
sit around and say oh well let's wait
till DNA sequencing was it developed is
developed so we can really find out
what's going on they did the best they
could with with the information they had
in one way or another all studies of
variation involved visible mutants
visible differences and so whether the
Morgan and others studied created the
foundations of genetics largely by
studying Drosophila the fruit fly and in
this species by the way they did it not
because they knew it was such great
study organisms because it was cheap
this was before NIH they could grow into
south phila bottles of drosophila in
milk bottles where they push bananas in
the bottom and the Flies they could keep
flies alive and then when they really
had no money they would take the milk
bottles to the doorstep where milkman
left clean bottles where clean bottles
were and swapped out the dirty ones and
for the younger people here milk bottles
are glass containers that used to that
milk used to be delivered in so and but
it turned out Drosophila was very nice
because it was you could grow lots of
them in each of these milk bottles and
there were many mutants once they look
started looking closely that were
visibly different so a short wing these
are just for of hundreds and hundreds of
mutants curly wing so with a little
practice and some add agility with
forceps you could sort through flies and
say oh here's a different one
and then you could see if it bred true
we do various crosses this allowed
Morgan to discover wreak a linkage and
genetic linkage and and prove the
chromosomal theory that his jeans were
inherit were physically located on
chromosomes chromosomes were known
before genes were known before but it
took some effort to prove that genes
were on chromosomes so so visible
mutants were very important and visible
mutants were studied in natural
populations to start some extent the
trouble is it was very very difficult to
say well what effect on survival and
reproduction these various forms had
sometimes you could guess the defective
wings could individually defective wings
would cause flies not to fly so well but
that's about as far as it went so 11
tradition in studying variation was
visible mutants second tradition came in
in human genetics starting with this
paper in 1902 garrard recognized that a
a rare but known disease called
alkaptonuria a condition where if an
individual has this it's a it's a
metabolic defect oh and it the one of
the phenotypic symptoms is that a
person's urine turns brown or even black
when exposed to sunlight and it as they
say ran in families but he proposed it
was specifically a man dealing and
recessive and verified this with various
family trees and then he found evidence
the various other what he called inborn
errors and metabolism were also mendeley
and recessive sedo fino phenyl ketonuria
is the most prominent of these but there
are many others so in human genetics
mendeley Mendelian traits were known and
people started examining Mendel ISM in
Mendelian inheritance in humans but
largely for a clinical not a not a
evolutionary reason nevertheless they
were studying variation in
in natural populations a more prominent
and probably the best known line of
research during this period was what we
call ecological genetics and ecological
genetics is based on the study of
polymorph ena typic polymorphisms so
species that has two or more distinct
forms that are easily recognizable and
inherited sometimes as a single
Mendelian trait or sometimes as a simple
combination of two or three Mendelian
traits and with these visible
polymorphisms the goal of ecological
genetics was to discover how natural
selection affected them and the classic
case and one that everyone who teaches
evolutionary biology including me
inflicts on students is the case of the
peppered moth which has a polymorphism
there's the melanic form and there's the
the wild-type or normal form and as most
of you probably know the melodic form is
at a disadvantage on normal trees
because they're visible and birds and it
kettlewell and others established that
birds actually do eat them with greater
frequency so they established the
mechanism of natural selection after
saying it occurred but saying here is
the agent the birds eat the dark ones
but then ended in central England trees
became black because of pollution from
industrialization and at that point the
light form was at a disadvantage and
indeed the the this species was
predominantly the melanic form in areas
affected by industrial pollution and
cattle well and ceases his students
showed in great detail exactly how
natural selection worked and then people
have continued this bedico ecological
genetics was pursued in many many other
organisms because you could do it you
could often do some simple inheritance
experiments establishing an end alien
basis for the
trade and you could do experiments in
nature looking at how different forms
were affected by ecological conditions
including visible predators or climatic
conditions particularly for plants or
interactions with pollinators or
something else I mean there were there
were ecological factors that you can
study that you could demonstrate where
the Asian agents of natural selection so
ecological genetics was important in in
convincing people that there were
practical examples of natural selection
going on in nature not just in in the
laboratory and finally and I would say
almost equally important for historical
reasons another visible mutant was the
distinct form that chromosomes had but
what is called the karyotype the
karyotype is the collection the
morphology of all the chromosomes
stained in a certain way and then hued
under a light microscope and here's an
example this is one chromosome from
drosophila lot of dubs on skis early
papers and dobzhansky was one of the
leading practitioners of this it happens
even almost an amazing accident it
happens that chromosomes in Drosophila
are very easy to study the in the
salivary glands they they multiply in
numbers so that when looked at under a
light microscope they're quite visible
so I mean technically it's an easy trait
it didn't have to be this way of it
could it could be other species but it
happened to be the very species that
that Morgan and others develop genetics
with here is an example here as a day of
a heterozygote for an inversion because
of the way DNA pairs if there is an
inversion that is if there's a section
that is just turned backwards then when
the chromosomes pair they form a loop
and so you this is a heterozygous
between hydro zygote between two named
inversions so
the sonoita and arrowhead and there are
many that are recognized in drosophila
and so these are morphological traits
that could be studied not quite with the
naked eye but fairly simply by looking
at the salivary glands under a light
microscope and so you could look at the
genotype directly remember everything
else was looking at the phenotype you're
looking at the genotype directly not
gene by gene but at least chromosome x
chromosome and bob jansky in particular
a russian geneticist who moved in the
united states in the 1930s or 1920s
spent his career studying inversion
polymorphisms and here's a slide from
one of his later papers showing this is
the frequency of the one of the myths on
iota inversion type that is the st yeah
the st chromosomes in different places
in western united states where the
Drosophila suit obscure occurs and at
different times because he had resampled
many of these areas and he showed that
there was abundant variation in space
and time he also showed that these
inversion polymorphisms were relatively
common they were not these were not rare
obviously defective traits they were
they were common enough to have moderate
frequencies and the frequencies varied
in space and time in a ways that he he
he characterized in great detail for
years and years of field studies and so
his conclusion was that these inversion
polymorphisms were affected by natural
selection and in particular by balancing
selection that is there was something
very good about heterozygotes that
caused selection to not be able to
eliminate any of the types now
dobzhansky in addition to being an
eminent geneticist one of Morgan's later
students
also was a very charismatic and
articulate proponent of neo-darwinism so
he became one of the leaders in the
neo-darwinian synthesis he's the one
credited he's the one who first said
nothing in in biology makes sense except
in the light of evolution something well
worth keeping in mind today so his
prominence in his his forcefulness of
character caused balancing selection to
become a a and possibly the major
mechanism for maintaining genetic
variation though even though he
discovered this only in Drosophila
pseudo obscura and a few other species
and he in using chromosomal variation
his views on the role of natural
selection became central to to the
neo-darwinian theory the alternative
theory for maintaining variation is some
version of mutation selection balance
where you have mutations creating rare
indeed alleles and then natural
selection eliminating them if they are
deleterious or substituting them driving
them to fixation if they're advantageous
but mutation selection balance does not
tend to maintain alleles in moderate
frequency mutation rates are very low
empirically and people found that they
were very low and so even weak natural
selection causes deleterious alleles to
be in low frequency this is something
called a and and others established okay
so this was the state of things until
the 1950s because there was no direct
way to observe the genotype of
individual low sigh you could only look
at the genotype of whole chromosomes in
the 1950s biochemistry developed to the
point that people could start to look at
individual amino acids this was the
first paper in 1956 which showed that
the difference between the
cell gene that was known to cause a
trade sickle-cell anemia that's common
especially in malarial regions in Africa
and Asia was attributable to a single
amino acid change in the in the beta
hemoglobin molecule so it was and this
was this at a profound effect people
talked about molecular diseases because
a single amino acid change in molecule
led to a recognizable clinical
deleterious condition and then amino
acid sequencing developed very rapidly
and zucher candle and Pauling in the
night early 1960s this isn't the the
first paper the first molecular clock
papers but it's the one I had on my desk
and they recognized very quickly that
comparing amino acid sequencing
sequences of different species could
tell you something about their
evolutionary history and because
differences between species would
accumulate only after those species had
separated from a common ancestor and
they introduced in the early 1960s the
notion of a molecular clock that is
proteins accumulated amino acid
differences roughly in proportion to the
time that those two species are
separated the profoundly important
discovery that they they made and other
people they've did it with globin
molecules and then margolia she did it
with cytochrome C and then everybody
sequenced everything and largely
verified the molecular clock hypothesis
now different proteins had different
clock rates so the accumulation of amino
acid differences took place at different
rates but for a particular protein the
rate was roughly constant in time very
important development in population
genetics the next important development
came in 1966 with the introduction
of a protein electrophoresis and the
idea is very simple that you take an
organism or you take an organism and
stain for a particular protein using
methods that were already known at that
time then you put the protein on the gel
or put the extract from the individual
stained on a gel and then you apply an
electric current from through the gel
from positive to negative or negative to
positive depending on the protein and
then the gel is very viscous and the
distance the the protein moves in a
standard period of time indicates
something about both its electric charge
and its spatial confirmation so if it's
long and skinny it will move more slowly
if it's tall compact it will move more
quickly in the same time so the gel
electrophoresis had been used already in
molecular biology many times what two
different groups did Harry Harris in
London with human proteins and hubby and
lewington at the University of Chicago
did was show that if you look very
carefully the distance moved on a gel
differs among individuals and
furthermore that these differences were
consistent if you're running under
standard conditions and sometimes you
can see a heterozygote where there are
two bands here sometimes you see a homo
or hetero zygote here whether two bands
sometimes you see only one band and you
interpret this as a homozygote and then
you do the breeding experiment to verify
that the bands are inherited exactly as
Mendelian alleles so this was
revolutionary because it didn't allowed
biologists for the first time to look at
the genotypes of individual low sigh in
a way that was both fairly cheap and
fairly easy it was something once you've
got the basic idea you could even build
your own gel boxes you didn't need
huge graphs to do this and all you
needed all you were limited by was your
ingenuity and staining proteins and
there were hundreds of protein stains
available so suddenly you could look not
just at one locus or too low side but
you could look at lots and lots of low
side because there were lots of soluble
proteins there were lots of components
of organisms that were not soluble and
could not be studied this way but still
it was a large number it was a lot more
than zero which was where they were
before now when lobby in lillington
looked at this and Harrison harriton
Harris looked at this for several
different proteins what they found was
that roughly thirty percent of the
proteins they could study this way were
polymorphic that they had to at least
two alleles and some have many more than
two alleles some had six or eight
different alleles segregating in a
single population or between populations
so they started to answer some of the
questions that I posed at the beginning
secondly they found that these alleles
were in moderate frequencies many of
them were not very rare in populations
but in frequencies twenty thirty forty
percent again like dojin skis of
inversion polymorphisms now this when
these papers were published this led to
an explosion first in empirical studies
because you could everybody could do
protein electrophoresis and within
fifteen years literally thousands of
species had been surveyed by this meets
and it also led to an explosion in
population genetics theory trying to
explain why there was so much variation
why so many low side were polymorphic
why allele frequencies were so high the
mutation selection balance theory did
not seem like a very convincing
explanation because the alleles were too
common that would seem to point to the
balance balancing selection explanation
but that had problems also because there
were so many low side if you extrapolate
saying 30
of the low side they didn't know how
many low side there were but they knew
there were thousands so we're talking
about thousands of low sigh that are
polymorphic if each one is maintaining
variation because there's balancing
selection favoring heterozygotes then a
little bit of calculation that I will
present will tell you there has to be a
huge variation in relative fitness in
the population that many individuals
should drop dead because they happen to
get a bad genetic draw and many
individuals should be super fit because
they happen to get a good very draw we
technically it's the variance in Fitness
was too large at the FCS people said the
genetic load was too large created by
balancing selection at so many low site
and so population geneticists many
people were brought into the field
attracted to the field because of the
excitement generated by these data be
included that's when I entered the field
now in 1968 Kimura presented a third
explanation saying no look it's not
mutation selection it's not balancing
selection most of the variation we see
is neutral that these parlays lleol
osiris polymorphic all right but they
are neutral they are not affected by
natural selection and so then there's no
problem there's no genetic load problem
there's no problem at all you just have
mutation creating new alleles and then
genetic drift slowly eliminating them
and Kimura and crow had shown that the
hetero zygosity under certain
assumptions is proportional to the
product of the effective population size
times the mutation rate the mutation
rate was known to be small and so the
prediction of the neutral theory is that
there should be a huge range in
heterozygosity because logically
ecologist tell some populations are very
small some populations had millions and
billions of individuals so hetero
zygosity should range from
almost zero to almost one fine well the
problem is that turned out empirically
not to be true here is a review for a
figure from a review article by a via
Tarnovo summarizing studies from 1111
electrophoretically here is the hetero
zygosity this is the average difference
in genotype between two individuals in
the same species are between two
chromosomes from the same species which
is to say every individual is
heterozygous at some fraction of the low
side and you can see there is an upper
limit here no species has a hetero
zygosity of more than thirty percent and
furthermore with in vertebrates tended
to be slightly more slightly Lecter's I
ghost in the invertebrates and slightly
less heterozygotes then plant but there
was there seemed to be almost no
correlation between a parent population
size and the hetero zygosity and there
were no species that had the very high
site heterozygosity that you would
expect to see if the neutral theory were
literally true so this Richard Lewington
called the paradox of variation one
resolution cameras colleague Tomoko ohta
proposed is that well no way things
aren't exactly neutral the selection
coefficient is not zero it's simply very
small so when new mutations appear they
are very weakly selected and the
importance of selection depends on the
product of the population size and the
selection coefficient in very very big
populations smaller selection
coefficients come into play because this
number becomes greater than one and that
limits the hetero zygosity now that's a
nice explanation but the other thing
Kimura explained is the molecular clock
the neutral theory explains the
molecular clock
that you get a constant rate of
substitution in neutral alleles this
nearly neutral theory of ohta doesn't
have that property so you have all the
molecular clock results inconsistent
with the predictions of the nearly
neutral theory okay as I say it led to
an explosion of population genetics
theory one very notable development is
you the UN sampling formula which is the
sampling distribution of neutral alleles
in a finite population this was both an
extremely elegant result it also showed
that there was a much greater
mathematical depth to population
genetics then had previously been
appreciated and this also UN's work also
drew some very high level mathematicians
into the field people like John Kingman
Bob Griffiths and others who raised the
stakes of mathematical theory in
population genetics now DNA sequencing
was discovered was developed in the
1970s and applied in the 1980s to the
point that people could start looking at
the rate of DNA evolution and test the
molecular hike up clock hypothesis in
some detail and this is a compilation by
when Charlie and others in 1985 they
confirmed the neutral theory that is the
rate of substitution of nucleotides that
do not change an amino acid is roughly
constant or different kinds of proteins
the rate of nonsynonymous substitutions
that is the substitution that changes
the amino acid varies hugely from
protein to protein confirming and and
reinforcing the zucher candle and pawing
hypothesis now DNA was DNA sequencing
was too difficult initially to be
applied to very many of species to look
at within species variation Marty
Kreitman published a notable study in
1983 where he worked like a slave for
years to sequence 11 individuals of
drosophila melanogaster but they did
real development of with ins population
sequencing occurred with the the the
sequencing done of mitochondrial genome
mitochondrial genome is a circular
mitochondria are organelles cell
organelles that each has a little bit of
DNA in a circle about sixteen thousand
base pairs this is very easy to sequence
for technical reasons and it also was
much more variable at the sequence level
then these parts of it were a variable
at the sequence level then the
corresponding amount of nuclear
chromosome so the same amount of work
would get you ten times as much
polymorphism roughly speaking the
sequencing of mitochondrial DNA took off
in the 1980s with the development of the
polymerase chain reaction and one of the
one of the first discoveries was not
made by important discoveries was made
by alan Wilson laid out of there at
Berkeley at the time and what he showed
my toe the other thing about
mitochondrial DNA in case you don't know
it mitochondrial DNA is is transmitted
from mother to offspring so there's no
recombination your your your
mitochondrial genotype is your mother's
mitochondrial genotype plus any
mutations and her genotype was her
mother's genotype and so on back in time
necessarily mitochondrial DNA has a
history that's described by a tree
necessarily because you go back in time
eventually you'll it's a pure death
process you go back to a single common
ancestor this also brought in
phylogenetic thinking into population
genetics for the first time because now
things were not necessarily described in
allele frequencies they were described
in terms of trees
what Wilson presented was and his
collaborators presented was it might
account a tree of mitochondrial DNA s
from different humans which went to back
to a common ancestor necessarily they
named this the mitochondrial Eve and
they estimated that it lived about a
hundred and fifty thousand years ago
that is there was a female alive who
carried the ancestral of all
mitochondrial DNA s and modern humans
furthermore the structure of the tree
indicated by these black dots tells us
that the ancestor probably lived in
Africa rather than someplace else this
was the out of africa hypothesis which
profoundly changed our view of the
history of modern humans that all modern
humans descended from a population in
Africa roughly 150,000 years ago and not
a population not homo erectus which
lived in other parts in Eurasia long
before them over a million years ago now
many people misunderstood this result
and said well mitochondrial Eve is the
ancestor of all modern humans and that's
definitely not true and it's a
misconception that still persist this
individual carried the ancestor of all
mitochondrial DNA is but the ancestors
of nuclear chromosomes were in somebody
else probably there was a population of
individuals and all of them collectively
were the ancestors of all the modern
genome it's only the mitochondrial DNA
that has this and the Y chromosome has a
similar structure for males ok then
things developed very quickly in the
1990s there were lots of sequences of
individual genes PCR preliminary strain
reaction made this possible but the pace
picked up with the establishment of the
Human Genome Project and the tools
developed for the sequencing of the
human genome because once you develop
this sequence of one individual once you
find the sequence of one individual for
the species you have a reference genome
and then after that additional
sequencing becomes very easy
so still species for which there is a
reference genome are much much more
studied at the DNA sequence level than
individuals and species for which there
is no reference genome now the problems
still persist though this is a this is a
slide from a paper by malleshwaram
jawarski showing that the paradox of
heterozygosity is not resolved with DNA
sequencing this is these are
heterozygosity which is it's called
diversity here from a large number of
different organisms for which good
sequences are available for a sufficient
part of the genome there is still a
restricted range there is still no clear
correlation between effective population
size and and diversity to heterozygosity
so all of the new techniques we've that
we have available haven't really come
help that much we simply have a better
version of the paradox we have now but
sequencing has been extremely successful
and particularly in historical
reconstruction that is understanding the
history of species and the geography of
species in great detail one of the
moment notable discoveries is by this
sohini ramachandran and others stanford
showing that there is a clear gradient
in heterozygosity in human populations
as the distance from africa increases
it's not other the slope isn't it's not
very steep but there is a definite
consistent pic picture and it can be be
matched by simulations which show that
an out of africa population going
through a series of bottlenecks of
colonization of the rest of the world
takes place can produce a gradient in
heterozygosity that matches the the
observations so patterns in variation at
a global level within humans and other
species can be accounted for by
historical processes
you see similar patterns in drosophila
melanogaster which was a commensal with
humans that has lives in fruit stores
and even if you look in detail this is
John November a if you look in great
detail at genetic variation within
Europe you can with a principal
components diagram match the geography
the the geographic similarity with the
genetic similarity of individuals that
is even in an area as well mixed as
Europe there's a close correspondence
between geography and genetic proximity
and we've learned more about the history
of population sizes this is Leander
madly and urban graph showing the
history of population sizes of various
human populations and then Neanderthal
and denisa populations which join the
rest of the group so again we've learned
a lot about the history of individual
groups and we know quite a bit about the
relationship between Neanderthals and
Denisovans and modern humans and genetic
exchange between them all through the
development and application of modern
sequencing methods nevertheless there's
a great deal we don't know we have now
very good answer to what are the
patterns of change at the DNA sequence
level in great detail we've sequin
there's lots and lots of sequence data
and more every every hour but we don't
have good very answers to any of these
questions we don't really know what
maintains variation within a species we
know what the very a pattern is a
variation are but we still don't know
how important selection is Rasmus
Nielsen will tell you a lot about what
we do know about selection but the broad
answers are still not available we don't
know for differences between species how
much the phenotypic differences arise
from differences at the sequence level
or to reverse that how the difference is
that the sequence level appear at the
phenotypic level we don't know how
limiting mutation is we don't know how
important genetic drift and other
factors are in accounting for phenotypic
evolution we know drift is very
important of the sequence level so I I
will finish conclude with this just to
say we know a great deal and we know a
lot about the history of organisms but
in many ways were not any closer to
answering the fundamental questions
about the genetic basis of evolution and
we should be somewhat humble as a result
so thank you like a the fraction of
genes that are applying working well we
know the degree of polymorphism at the
DNA sequence level within genes between
genes coding differences non-coding
differences I mean like everything is
fine well that mean I mean there are
different levels of heterozygosity as
that diagram showed there are some genes
that are almost not at all polymorphic
and coding differences some genes that
have a lot of coding differences also
like if I if I can change like the word
between to bone and if I take you know I
think like a sample of a million page
and like a tiny bit of sea water right
easy right there's something do we have
some sense of what the differences are
going to be among that set well people
certainly have done sequencing studies
of phage and seawater right exactly and
I mean I don't happen to know what the
results are but those are those results
aren't known are known what we don't
know is why what accounts for the
differences or any million people right
I generally have a thousand rate uh did
for the tens of thousands already okay
okay cool so if I want to talk about how
all of them will be late
not just paralyzed but like your full
set what distribution of differences
will have that's all it's always well I
knew that November's graph that i showed
you chose that for example within Europe
you get increasing difference between
individuals as you increase geographic
distance that's between those two
principal components that is you can
take a person to genotype and locate
amount of graph within 50 miles of I
mean at least for people who haven't
moved around a lot they usually you do
it with grandparents because mobility
was a lot less than that generation I
think the do wheat that's that's like
you know that's a very restricted view
of like the full diversity rice the
first two principal components do we
know what like is there is it would
there be some cool other ways of looking
at the data make I'm sure there are but
I think it's a bigger challenge to
account for why the differences are what
they are what was so special about the
chromosomes in the saliva glands of
drosophila they I mean it's Chuck here
is he yeah yeah you tell them well let
me just preface that with
one thing one thing that Monty didn't
put on his slide that you should realize
that the first half of the of that
century of population genetics after the
structure eating
compared to the material actual
narrative material was so these people
were doing population genetics of genes
for which there was no concept it was
widely debated what a gene was alone
whether what a real one anyway so the
salivary glands it just turned as Monty
said it just turned out that in certain
tissues of some insects and a few other
organisms if the cell is not going to
divide in your longer the chromosomes
are just replicated meaning incoming
which makes giant 12 giant salivary
gland chromosomes any other organisms
have similar thing and those made those
accessible to actual genotyping whereas
up until the advent of electrophoresis
they're essentially with no meaningful
source of genetic variation in natural
populations other than continuous
variation it could be easily study
probably I should preface that thing
along people work in cooking the early
drosophila sandy mutants that you
because of molars Nobel Prize had worked
on the pregnancy were sensibly those are
widely studied and those definitely fit
the
well quite well and they do to this day
and in fact you can estimate how big the
population size is from distribution of
these successfully
they were so so but since then yeah in
drosophila okay got a daughter who's in
drosophila have has had these
chromosomes being also visualized in
other organs or it's just a little
working yeah other owns water saw in the
other work at other tissues of the book
in the sound very glam it turns out that
the it's called politicisation
replication of the problem in the salary
glance it's essentially the whole gene
space that continues what's called the
euchromatin his rover replicated in
other tissues where there has to be a
lot of gene expression that are
different that are terminal and I'm
going to deny there's politan is a shin
of part of the genome and that makes our
message psychology and so people do that
molecularly rather than visually these
were quite beautiful and they had a very
they they have a beer
the reason of chance be studied them so
long in my view is the aesthetics
they're quite beautiful especially if
you learn them
you should take a break